quatre cent soixante et unième jour de
détention pour perry anderson
il reste 14 otages occidentaux au liban
l'accord sans voix de paralysie for
their port bloqué après les
fonctionnaires beaucoup de commerces et
entreprises en grève aujourd'hui
municipal à trois jours du second tour
bras de fer à gauche discipline à droite
invité de ce journal du rpr edouard
balladur l'agriculture soviétique est un
désastre mikhaïl gorbatchev en dresse le
bilan devant le plénum du comité central
à moscou la france championne du monde
cinq fois plus d'opérations de la peine
ici qu'ailleurs en europe une enquête
dans les milieux médicaux
madame monsieur bonsoir la corse
pratiquement paralysé aujourd'hui le
président de l'assemblée corse l'opl
dans caceres en appelle au premier
ministre pour qu'il ait lieu le plus
vite possible des négociations qui
débloque la longue grève des
fonctionnaires commerçants et
entrepreneurs ont été nombreux
aujourd'hui à se joindre au mouvement
sur place françoise joly la grève ici
injection n'en parle et pas seulement
aux terrasses de café aujourd'hui les
commerçants ont fermé leurs boutiques
pour demander au gouvernement de
débloquer la situation
mais ce matin chez les commerçants
c'était un peu la confusion hier soir
nous a demandé de fermer tous les gens à
tous les commerçants de la rue ont
décidé de fermer les ai suivis vous a
demandé fermé et commerçants de la rue
et pourquoi ils ferment les magasins
pour protester contre quoi
les commerçants et oui
la grève depuis aujourd'hui des
contrôleurs aériens des pompiers de
l'aéroport de campo dell'oro ajaccio ici
aucun avion n'a pu atterrir ni décoller
et puis il ya cette grève qu'on
n'attendait pas celle du personnel d'air
france corse
celui ci perçoit déjà une prime
d'assiduité mais là les grévistes
demandent plus d'effectifs nous n'avons
pas tout à fait le même rôle d'éducation
mais on s'associe quand même à leurs
revendications pour que le mouvement
soit un peu plus amplifiée qu'il est
quand même plus de deux prises d'un pour
nous parce que on risque d'avoir besoin
les transports maritimes sont eux aussi
bloqués trois bateaux attendent ce soir
dans le port d'ajaccio
les agents des ptt de l'équipement des
impôts les empêche d'appareiller pour
marseille ou pour nice
chaque jour le mouvement de grève prend
de l'ampleur dans la fonction publique
les employés municipaux à bastia comme à
ajaccio on peut aussi arrêter le travail
dans l'île
on attend maintenant un geste du
gouvernement l'état lui est ferme
il exclut une augmentation du salaire
des fonctionnaires en revanche il est
décidé à regarder de très près la
question du coût de la vie sur l'île
enfin il veut également s'assurer que
les différentes subventions de l'état
sont bien employé elle s'appelle salomé
elle a trois ans elle n'a jamais vu son
père elle est née quelques semaines
après l'enlèvement à beyrouth de terry
anderson terry anderson 41 en amérique
un journaliste qui est aujourd'hui
quelque part dans beyrouth otages du
jihad islamique otage depuis quatre ans
quatre ans tout juste
aujourd'hui dans quel état on n'en sait
rien ils sont encore 14 otages
occidentaux au liban terje andersen est
le plus ancien d'entre eux et plus
personne n'en parle
plusieurs organisations de journalistes
ont tenu en ce triste jour anniversaire
rappeler leurs souvenirs et notre
indignation à la tête du mouvement jean
paul kauffmann qui a strasbourg a déposé
une motion au parlement européen michel
mompontet des photos envoyées au compte
gouttes par ses ravisseurs
raconte son calvaire pas besoin de mots
pour comprendre
terry anderson est titulaire d'un
horrible record il est l'otage
occidental le plus ancien toujours
détenus au liban 16 mars 1985 16 mars
1989 comme des repères dans le temps ces
cassettes vidéo toujours le même texte
dicté par le djihad islamique ce jihad
qu'il a capturés dans beyrouth ouest il
y à 1460 jours
mais depuis six mois le compte gouttes
sinistre de ces images s'est interrompu
sa famille parle de ses souffrances bien
sûr mais elle parle surtout de l'oubli
l'oubli qui guette les otages du liban
ce qui est de pire dans la vie d'un
otage ce n'est pas ce ne sont pas les
mauvais traitements ce ne sont pas nés
les yeux bandés
ce n'est pas le fait de jeu ne pas voir
la lumière du jour de ne pas voir le
soleil les arbres de vivre dans une ase
peut faire profiter tous la cccc c'est
très dur c'est horrible même mais je
crois que ce qui est le pire c'est le
sentiment d'être oubliés d'être
abandonnée au parlement de strasbourg
aujourd'hui ils ont tenté de réveiller
les mémoires
jean paul kauffmann et la famille
jacqueline valente pour que les 14
otages encore au liban ne soit pas 14
otages
oublié au liban aujourd'hui donc mille
quatre cent soixante et unième jour de
détention pour terry anderson une
centaine d'instituteurs au nom de leur
coordination ont pris la bastille
aujourd'hui manifestation surprise
toujours contre le plan jospin en
revanche la situation se débloque du
côté de l'enseignement supérieur la
majorité des syndicats viennent de
signer un accord avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale chantal qui meurt
on songe active dominé propositions
gouvernementales nette amélioration du
salaire en début de carrière
mille francs de plus pour un maître de
conférences débutant son salaire mensuel
passera de huit mille deux cents francs
à 9200 francs nette accélération de
carrière plus grande facilité pour les
maîtres de conférences à devenir
professeur en dehors de ces
modifications statutaires
le ministère propose une revalorisation
indemnitaire tous les enseignants du
supérieur recevront une prime de base de
6200 francs par an à cette prime de base
s'ajouteront différentes primes pour la
formation la recherche ou
l'administration qui pourra toucher ses
primes et dans quelles conditions
c'est un problème qui a amené le
syndicat fo à ne pas signer l'accord
quant au syndicat des enseignants du
supérieur
ils restent très réservés
dans ses conclusions il y avait un
certain nombre de réponses à certaines
de nos revendications pour lesquelles
nous du temps depuis des années en même
temps il y a eu une sorte de marchandage
du chantage
et effectivement il y avait eu
introduction d'un système d'indemnités
que nous avons dénoncées depuis le début
incontestablement lionel jospin marque
ce soir un pas en avant dans les
négociations avec les enseignants du
supérieur
une embellie dans le difficile dossier
de la revalorisation des enseignants qui
empoisonne depuis des mois les relations
entre le gouvernement et les enseignants
en tout cas la grande des enseignants et
populaire 54% des français les
soutiennent selon un sondage publié
cette semaine par l'hebdomadaire la vie
à trois jours du second tour des
municipales toujours le bras de fer est
l' échange d'amabilités entre
états-majors socialistes et communistes
la situation reste bloquée ce soir à
sarcelles ou le pc vous savez ma tient
sa liste contre le secrétaire national
du ps et ce malgré les injonctions de
pierre mauroy
georges marchais s'élèvent contre ce qui
lui paraît une dramatisation de la
situation et dans un entretien que
publiera demain l'est républicain michel
rocard s'attriste lui sur le sort des
électeurs communistes le pc dit il tend
à devenir un parti régional il ya moins
de grincements à droite
en tout cas entre le rpr et l'udf
puisque à aix en provence le candidat
rpr obéi qu'à alain juppé et s'efface au
profit du maire sortant udf monsieur
balladur
bonsoir l'ordre règle donc au rpr la
satisfaction aussi semble-t-il puisque
grâce quelques succès éclatant comme
ceux de michel maure philippe seguin
alain carignon l'état major du rpr se
félicite mais ce que vous n'êtes pas un
tout petit peu en train de récupérer
comme l'on dit le succès de ses hommes
politiques locaux qui ont joué en fait
leur carte personnelle avant celle du
rpr
oh écoutez il ya d'autres d'abord je me
réjouis beaucoup de succès de ce que
vous n'êtes nommé mais y en a d'autres
il ya celui de jacques chirac à paris
gagnait 13 arrondissements sur 20
au premier tour ce qui est tout à fait
remarquable et il y en ad'autres un peu
partout en france
nous verrons le second tour il est tout
à fait prématuré de se réjouir à
l'avancé mais enfin on peut dire compte
tenu des résultats du premier tour que
le rpr et l'udf font mieux qu'il n'était
prévu surtout contenu point de départ
qui était 1983 qu'avec un très grand
succès pour eux et dans ces conditions
je trouve ça extrêmement encourageants
ils font mieux grâce à leurs efforts
d'union et de renouvellement et je me
réjouis pour ma part chaque fois que de
nouveaux candidats ou des hommes et
femmes femmes jeunes ou à écouter sur ma
10 dans le 15e arrondissement il y en
avait à 17
oui mais je le battrai qui n'avait 17
sur 51 candidats un tiers c'est pas si
mal
monsieur balladur est ce que la victoire
néanmoins de michel noir à lyon est ce
que l'on peut dire que c'est une
victoire pour jacques chirac de produire
père n'est pas venu soutenir michel
radio si michel noir avaient été battus
ça aurait été une victoire pour jacques
chirat voyons écoutez il faut raisonner
de façon objective
moi je suis très heureux la victoire de
michel noir parce que c'est la victoire
du renouvellement et je crois qu'il est
très utile que tous les partis
politiques se ferment le moins possible
et fasse le plus d'effort possible pour
être ouvert sur les nouvelles
générations les nouveaux talents et dans
ces conditions mieux vaut jose assure
monsieur leclerc mieux vaut gérer avec
les difficultés que ça peut procurer la
richesse et la diversité que d'avoir à
faire face à la pauvreté
ces personnes vont prendre du poids
quand même en étant attendue mais je
l'espère bien
ça va quand même impliqué
en jouant deux rapports de force entre
générations en quelque sorte comme le
disait ah c'est carrément l'udf gérard
longuet hier sur europe 1 je crois noir
et carignon ce n'est pas parce qu ils
baladent vieux donc c'est vrai mais moi
je me sens extrêmement jeunes comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure avant que
l'émission ne commence puisque ma
carrière politique n'a que trois en
trois ans tout juste ses données en
politique il n'ya pas plus jeune que moi
en politique d'un mot sur lyon thomas
monsieur balladur la défaite de raymond
barre vous avez une interprétation un
commentaire oh non j'ai pas
d'interprétation particulière ce la
défaite des listes c'est pas une défaite
personnelle de raymond barre 2000 n'en
ai pas le sentiment ce qui me concerne
je crois que c'est surtout un problème
de génération et un problème de comment
vous dire de besoin de renouvellement
qui s'est fait sentir à lyon comme ça se
fait sentir dans beaucoup de régions de
villes de france est moins sévère à son
encontre qu'à françois léotard dimanche
ça c'est habituel de ma part les
municipales dessine aussi de nouveaux
rapports de force semble t-il entre le
rpr et l'udf al avantage d herbert
c'est l'impression clonage hummer femmes
et attendons je le répète les résultats
du deuxième tour dimanche prochain ce
qui me paraît comptait beaucoup plus que
tel ou tel rapport de forces c'est
l'union de l'ensemble de l'opposition
son union et je le répète son
renouvellement
et je souhaite beaucoup qu'une fois ces
élections municipales passées on en tire
les conclusions qui s'imposent pour les
élections européennes et façon générale
pour l'organisation de l'union de
l'opposition elle n'a pas très bien vécu
l'année qui vient de se passer
après la défaite de 1988 et comme j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire elle n'est
pas encore un recours crédible il faut
qu'elle le devienne
autrement dit lis kenny je prendrai une
ambiance unique pour les élections
européennes et surtout une liste là
aussi profondément renouvelée et par
exemple pourquoi ne pas le dire à haute
voix
je souhaite que les candidats du rpr en
position d'être élues sur sept listes
soient très largement des jeunes et des
personnalités nouvelles et plus tard
confédération et quand tu as l'air perdu
c'est votre idée organisation meilleurs
ne brûlons pas les étapes pour moi
tellement reproché d'avoir parlé de
confédérations il ya un an je suis
devenu très prudent et commençons par
mieux vous organiser on peut envisager
de créer un intergroupe commun
l'assemblée nationale et on peut
envisager de commencer à travailler
ensemble à l'élaboration de ce qui
pourrait être un projet pour l'avenir
mais je vais les deux revenants quand
même aux municipales vous leurs
appreniez tout à l'heure il reste à ce
bateau qui peut coûter à votre parti
quelques villes importantes c'est le cas
d'avignon comme nous l'expliqué pascal
bing entre deux tours en trompe-l'oeil
ici élections se dit bien conclave mais
qui entre pape tout sortir simple
cardinal
rien n'est joué en avignon théâtre
d'ombrés pour pièces à suspense mardi
l'intrigué se noue est à quelques heures
du dépôt des listes matin chagrin pour
leur gardien mais rebondissement après
midi après un tour de piste du côté de
la mairie les écolos décidé de jouer la
carte rasier autre électorat dans les
second tour lorsque ne donnant pas de
consigne de vote
vote un peu plus majoritairement à
gauche
donc nous pensons que c'était le
meilleur choix un choix purement
tactique pour les verts plutôt une bonne
affaire pour le ps reste une ombre au
tableau les communistes qui refusent
d'appeler à voter socialiste au second
tour
mais guy ravier espère un réflexe que
les électeurs communistes ne suive pas
les consignes l'appareil à droite aussi
on fait ses comptes
entre chien et loup à l'heure où sortent
les colleurs d'affichés le maire rpr
rencontre devant ses troupes de ses
négociations avec le front national jean
pierre roux c'est vrai n'a jamais été
tendre avec les amis de jean marie le
pen mais l'arithmétique électorale a ses
raisons que le coeur ne connaît pas
tractations interruption reprises et
finalement rupture le front national se
maintient au second tour
la pièce se jouera donc à trois on dit
triangulaire on pense faut-il sais je
vais aujourd'hui à la bataille des
municipales
croyez bien que je le fais quand même un
petit peu à contrecoeur car
j'aimerais pas que les socialistes
passent le maire quant à lui choisi le
silence publication d'un simple
communiqué la liste rpr udf du premier
tour remonte sur scène distribution
inchangé seule différence
jean pierre roux ne veut plus parler ne
veut plus être filmés désormais en
avignon tout dépend des reports de voix
guy ravier croit avoir partie gagnée
le maire lui se dit toujours assuré de
l'emporter jusqu'au tomber le rideau
final tout peut basculer
au soir du premier tour 198 voix pas une
de plus séparé les deux têtes d'affiché
le front national ne décolère pas
jacques chirac a déclaré la guerre à nos
électeurs affirme le secrétaire général
du parti
une guerre laquelle vous souscrivez
monsieur balladur vous coûter
n'employons pas de mots excessifs
il faut davantage être cohérent à faire
soi même nous avons sur un certain
nombre de sujets des façons de voir
différentes on en tire les conclusions
sur le plan électoral inutile pour
autant de s'injurier qui suivent à la
dire merci un mois encore de la campagne
municipale à dunkerque aucune piste ni
revendication après la tentative
d'attentât la nuit dernière contre la
voiture de michel delbarre le candidat
socialiste à la mairie
la police a ouvert une enquête
une autre enquête est publiée cette
semaine dans la revue impact médecin
elle fait beaucoup de bruit dans les
milieux médicaux
on y apprend que nous sommes en france
les champions du monde de l'appendicite
ou plutôt de l'opération que l'on
pratique très volontiers pour s'en
débarrasser trop volontiers peut-être
40% des opérations serait inutile alors
pourquoi un tel excès même si le
diagnostic est particulièrement
difficile en la matière dans les
françoises rivaux avec 400 mille
opérations par an l'appendicectomie zié
très largement en tête des opérations
digestives un français sur trois la
subira la france détient un record dans
ce domaine
cette opération il est cinq fois plus
fréquente que dans les autres pays
européens
les difficile de croire que la fréquence
de l'appendicite aiguë et plus élevé en
france que dans les autres pays donc
forcé d'admettre que les médecins ont
qu'une peur de l'appendicite et gül
chirurgien également et qu'il y à
beaucoup d'appels secte ami de prudence
il est vraisemblable que dans toutes les
familles
un arrière-grand-oncle qui est mort il
ya 50 ans ou 60 ans d'une appendicite et
du crâne et cette mentalité n'a pas
changé la prudence des habitudes et
souvent la pression familiale vont donc
conduire le médecin à choisir
l'opération devant cette série de
symptômes j'étais à l'école c'est comme
le cerveau neuf entrées et à la tête et
que j'avais envie de vomir
donc on a appelé le médecin qui
qu'effectivement diagnostiqué une crise
d'appendicite m'inquiétais pas pour lui
alarmant dans la mesure où rien n'est
pas sienne et il a conseillé
effectivement si la situation s'aggrave
et un peu dans la nuit de violents maux
ici directement c'est ce qu'on a fait il
ya énormément de énormément de symptômes
qui se traduisent par une douleur en
garde et notamment toute la pathologie
coliques entraîne volontiers une
distension du c'est comme étant de la
partie droite du côlon et ça fait mal à
cet endroit de même beaucoup de
pathologies gynécologiques sur l'eau
vers droit donne des douleurs qui
ressemble à l'appendicite
une enquête menée dans toute la france
sur 2000 opération a mis en évidence que
si 10% d'entre elles étaient réels non
urgentes 40% en revanche aurait pu être
évité va-t-on revenir sur le principe de
la retraite à 60 ans instaurée en 80
hier dans le journal le monde
théo braun qui s'occupe au gouvernement
des personnes âgées soulevé la question
et se prononcer pour une modulation de
l'âge de la retraite
le problème est complexe il touche à la
démographie au financement des régimes
de retraite
il touche aussi à la psychologie et au
mode de vie il est vrai que si beaucoup
de gens surtout dans les professions
pénibles tiennent à une retraite précoce
d'autres s'y sentent acculés par les
difficultés économiques
fbt pierre de guillou 68 ans aujourd'hui
s'est arrêtée de travailler à 60 ans
c'était un choix à l'époque la retraite
à 60 ans n'existait pas encore
pour cet ancien métallurgiste au travail
depuis l'âge de 14 ans la retraite à 60
ans est un repos bien mérité avec tous
les ailleurs c'est hadj diallo goff à
lyon et nanterre
c'était un mal qui explique par tient
qu'à terme est d'être à l'aise d'avoir
la liberté de pouvoir faire qu'est ce
qu'on peut avec les moyens qu'on l'a
bien sûr les moyens financiers pour la
nes et permettait pas de contraintes de
les riders ont fait rater l'heure de
repartir un peu en vacances tu n'as pas
ta qui en a conçu comme on veut
compterait donc on veut pas faire qu'est
ce qu'on veut fernand l'ange lui a
plutôt subi sa retraite il a aujourd'hui
59 ans en 1985
là où ip une société fabriquant des
instruments de précision où il travaille
depuis trente trois ans réduit ses
effectifs
un plan social prévoit le départ en pré
retraite à 55 ans de 15 salariés
fernand l'ange est de ceux là pour moi
personnellement ça ça a posé des
problèmes disons moral bon effectivement
il ya eu une perte de salaire c'est un
fait certain bassa'a papa du tiers de
madame appels de mes revenus
bon mais dans le fond c'était à mon avis
était pas encore même si ça son
importance était encore 16 c'est le ca
l'importance l'important c'était de se
voir privés de travail d'avoir pris le
travail en pleine force et de pas mal de
choix de le faire la retraite objet
d'une aspiration légitime ou exclusion
mal acceptée du monde du travail ou de
la des lois sur l'âge de la retraite
entre ces deux extrêmes une multitude de
façons de vivre l'après travail greffes
partielles dans le métro parisien cet
après-midi sur les lignes 7 et 11 grève
de solidarité après la tentative de viol
encore une dot et dont a été victime ce
matin une jeune femme agent station et
puis à paris toujours manifestation de
plusieurs milliers de salariés de la
société dassault leurs syndicats
craignent la contraction des activités
du groupe aéronautique à moscou ce soir
les membres du plénum du comité central
du parti communiste soviétique sont en
train de se disperser sur la place rouge
depuis hier michael gorbatchev a ouvert
un nouveau front dans la bataille de la
pérestroïka des changements le front de
l'agriculture l'a dit culture soviétique
dit-il est dans un état catastrophique
jorge portal lèche bien descendu
semblait dire monsieur gorbatchev à des
agriculteurs de la région de moscou en
cette l'agriculture monsieur gorbatchev
connaît bien puisqu'il a été responsable
du secteur agricole avant de devenir
secrétaire général
ce qui fait dire à ses détracteurs qu'il
a sa part de responsabilité dans le
marasme qui persiste puisque aujourd'hui
encore l'urss doit compléter ses
récoltes par les achats aux états unis
et puisque le bétail se refuse
obstinément à donner assez de viande et
de lait pour nourrir les villes
le remède monsieur gorbatchev a dit hier
et aujourd'hui aux membres du comité
central que le paysan doit devenir
maître de la terre ce qui veut dire que
les exploitations individuelles pourrait
naître ce qui veut dire que des paysans
pourrait louer de la terre à eux pour
qu'ils pourraient y cultiver ce qu'ils
veulent et non pas ce que leur impose le
plan il manque une précision dans ce
beau programme quand pourra-t-il être
appliqué sur la réalisation de ces
projets monsieur corbacho fresque dans
le flou peut-être parce que ceux qui
l'écoutent et qui l'encadrent ne le
laisserait pas aujourd'hui se lancer
dans le libéralisme grande première en
tout cas à moscou jusqu'ici les
caricatures des membres du gouvernement
y était interdite et bien crocodile la
revue satirique publie cette semaine un
photomontage du ministre de l'irrigation
et d'économie fluvial avec la légende
suivante non seulement nous avons assez
chez des millions d'hectares de terres
mais nous avons ensuite irriguées sans
commentaire supplémentaire
les grecs on vous pourrit ces derniers
mois de leur ministre et surtout du
premier d'entre eux george papandréou
empêtré vous le savez dans des histoires
de coeur et d'argent qui minent son
autorité pour gagner du temps son
gouvernement a démissionné aujourd'hui
jérôme baugnies la dernière manoeuvre
politique d'andréas papandréou aboutit à
un paradoxe
tous les membres de son gouvernement
démissionne sauf le plus éclaboussé par
le scandale lui même le premier ministre
à l'origine de la crise que traverse
aujourd'hui la démocratie grecque cet
homme georges coste quotas ce patron de
la banque de crète
aujourd'hui poursuivie pour
malversations c'est avec la bénédiction
de papandréou proclame-t-il de sa prison
américaine que l'équivalent de plus d'un
milliard de francs a été détournée afin
de mettre sur pied un puissant groupe de
presse
favorable au gouvernement papandréou
déjà dans le collimateur de la presse à
scandale pour sa liaison avec la jeune
hôtesse de l'air dimitra liany contre
attaque sans convaincre
dénonçant la machination de centre de
déstabilisation grecs et étrangers
hier soir à l'appel de la gauche
cinquante mille manifestants défilent à
athènes pour réclamer la démission du
gouvernement
aux cris de dehors les voleurs
aujourd'hui le remaniement ministériel
décidé par papandréou fait figure d'un
nouvel écran de fumée dans ce trouble
feuilleton à rebondissements qui risque
trois mois avant les élections
législatives grecques de faire le jeu
des adversaires de la démocratie
aujourd'hui dans le procès du
commissaire joe big pause bienvenue
après les passes d'armes violente entre
le policier le juge
hayat le milieu compte les points
prostituée indicateurs témoignent tantôt
contre l'un tantôt contre l'autre et
voilà que le sous directeur de la police
judiciaire de paris portent plainte à
son tour contre le juge hayat pour
diffamation publique en toile de fond le
stylite est ouverte entre deux
institutions
la police et la magistrature rémy roche
dès le premier jour la sphère est
explosive un commissaire accusé de
toucher de l'argent de la part de
prostituées et d'entretenir d'étranges
rapport avec ces indicateurs parole de
prostituées contre celle d'un policier
devant le tribunal il jobic fait front
mais croit bon pour assurer sa défense
de mettre en cause l'intégrité de celui
qui a instruit son dossier parole de
commissaires contre celle d'un magistrat
le juge hayat
le ton monte d'autant que le juge en
question
soutenu par ses pairs passe à son tour à
la tac je suis victime dit il en
substance d'une machination montée par
la hiérarchie policière afin de
discréditer mon enquête
on s'invective on se traite de menteur
et au bout du compte on oublie presque
l'histoire des prostituées et des
enveloppes désormais deux institutions
s'affrontent c'est la parole de la
police contre celle de la justice
jusqu'où ira le face à face
quelles en seront les conséquences
il y a une fracture actuellement mais ce
n'est pas une opposition globale entre
policiers et magistrats
c'est vrai qu'il ya un problème on ne
peut pas le nier mais il ne faut pas que
ce soit l'arbre qui cache la forêt il y
a plusieurs milliers de magistrats
il y a plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
policiers
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
gendarmes qui tous les jours pour la
sécurité des personnes et des biens
travaillent ensemble efficacement sans
faire de bruit il ya d'abord la règle de
droit qui nous lie tous
il ya surtout le fait que et c'est à
tous les magistrats d'en prendre
conscience que plus que jamais
procureurs et juges d'instruction se
doivent d'appliquer avec beaucoup de
fermeté les règles du code de procédure
pénale sur la direction de la police
judiciaire
cette affaire nous renvoie à nos
responsabilités quant au contrôle de
l'action de la police judiciaire plus
que jamais
peut-on espérer aller vers un apaisement
les débats reprennent demain après 24
heures de réflexion pour tout le monde
bram en formule 1 philippe streiff le
pilote totalement paralysé il a été
opéré la nuit dernière au brésil
lionel chamoulaud un virage manqué sur
le circuit de jacarepagua la jeunesse et
à plus de 200 kilomètres heure elle
s'envole à deux mètres du sol pour
percuter rail à 80 mètres de là beaucoup
de monde rapidement sur les lieux mais
les secours efficaces sont à attendre
sur le circuit les médecins et
chirurgiens qui le fait présent ne sont
pas là le rapatriement sur un hôpital
tarbes
le choc est terrible dans un premier
temps les informations concernant l'état
de philippe sont rassurantes transporté
enfin à l'hôpital il est opéré une
opération de trois heures dans
l'après-midi le bulletin de santé est
affreux philippe et paralyser totalement
lucide mais tétraplégique le professeur
seyant se rend à son chevet ce rêve se
fait connaître à la suite de cet
accrochage avec son équipier d'alors
jacques laffite
nous sommes en 1985 en australie
philippe obtient là son unique podium
pilotes et homme d'affaires il s'est
toujours battu pour trouver des
partenaires financiers pour courir avec
succès philippe a couru 54 grand prix de
formule 1 pour renault
ligier et tyrrell et à js c'était sa
passion elle la brise est à 33 ans ce
soir on pense à lui
à sa femme à ses deux garçons courage
philippe patinage artistique à bercy à
l'épreuve aujourd'hui les de duchesnay
soutenus par leur public
ont-ils convaincu leurs juges terrible
en pro ce canotiers l'objet du délit
commis par paul duchesnay
si en plus isabelle arrive avec un bord
il y a de quoi crisper les juges
difficile de leur faire admettre que ce
sont des partis costumes et non des
accessoires interdit par le règlement
les duchesnay savait qu'ils jouaient ce
qui motive sable c'est là où la
curiosité dans la recherche et puis je
pense que l'or leur plaisir de patiner
n'est pas seulement tourné vers la
compétition est aussi tournée vers le
vers le professionnalisme et que pour se
réaliser dans dans ce qu'ils veulent
faire plus tard les ont besoin de se
libérer d'un an règlement accessoires
évolutions libres trop livre bref une
médaille sacrifié sur l'autel de la
créativité
tout le monde est dans quelque chose
prend de nouveau rendre aussi celle
d'alice à l'esprit saint
le public a aimé beaucoup même les juges
nettement moins cinquième seulement du
programme pourquoi les isabelle ne sont
plus que quatrième au classement général
commentaire signé patrick naf et n'ont
pas tiré d'un conte les résultats du
tiercé et du kart et qui se sont
discutées aujourd'hui à evry le tir
c'est d'abord le 18 le 19 et le 9 5
francs dans l'ordre rapport 40000 18
francs 50 dans un ordre différent 7086
francs touvron et le quartier donc 18 19
9 et 12 dans l'ordre 700 4185 francs un
gros porc et dans un ordre différent
35500 68 francs 50 juste après la pub
laurent cabrol va vous parler du temps
de demain deux rendez vous encore avec
la formation sur un thème de ce soir
vers 22h vous avez rendez vous avec
claude sérillon qui est à marseille pour
une édition spéciale consacrée bien sûr
à cette ville en effervescence
électorale encore avant le second tour
ensuite que philippe lefait vous donnera
les dernières informations de la journée
demain 6h45 vous retrouverez ranger
isabelle et à 7h45 c'est hervé bourges
l'ancien patron de tf1 nathan le patron
de rmc tmc qui répondra aux questions de
gérard morin très bonne soirée sur
antenne 2 à demain matin